the coven 19 pandemic the level of
uncertainty about it shouldn't have been
there that seemed to have been there i
mean we know that pandemics happen
we know that pandemics at this scale
happen you know it's it's
shocking to us because we haven't
experienced something like this in our
lifetimes but we all knew
it was modeled like that something like
this was going to happen and we were
completely unprepared globally and not
only were we unprepared globally but
the fact that so many people
in the world are just caught up in these
concerns about whether it's a hoax or
these conspiracies i mean
it's really very simple measures that
need to be taken to control the spread
of this pandemic that we all knew was
coming
it's very clear that our communication
and collaboration systems are
very broken and things are heavily
politicized
i'm joined by mara cortona maru welcome
to the show
thank you pleasure to have you on so
what do we what are we going to be
talking about today
um i'd love to talk about existential
risk
and the way that we relate to it as
individuals and and as societies
positive conversation for us today then
everyone feeling good leaving this
leaving leaving this in fear of the
world stopping
it's something that really troubles me
that people aren't concerned about more
than they are
both existential risk and global
catastrophic risks
um to the point that it is something
that i tend to bring up in casual
conversation which makes me very fun at
parties
um but it is a thing that i
i really think we should be talking
about more so here we are
what do we need to know about to start
then what's the the glossary of words
and key terms or whatever it is that we
need to be aware of before we can begin
sure um well i initially i think i'd
like to draw a distinction between
x-risk or existential risk which is
a risk to the entire species as we know
it and
global catastrophic risks which
perhaps wouldn't cause the entire
extinction
of our species but would lead to
mass die-offs and a really low quality
of life
and those are those types of risks are
both more likely to happen
and more likely to happen sooner than
the major types of
x-risks that are frequently modeled and
talked about so
those are important things to discuss
some of the main
some of the most critical and pressing
forms of x-risk obviously climate change
is the one on everyone's mind
though engineered pandemics bioweapons
and um nuclear war are are right up
there so it's really all they're really
all anthropo
excuse me anthropic um risks
and those are distinct from sort of this
background rate of existential risk
that's always there
from like asteroid collisions or
perhaps natural pandemics or super
volcanoes or the like
there's always this background risk of
those happening which is fairly low
as we have been on this planet
to in some degree for um you know 2000
centuries and we we haven't come across
anything like that yet
so we're at the point where um
those natural background risks are far
outweighed
by the anthropic risks that are being
precipitated and accelerated by our own
activity
so those are some of the main the main
terms that i use the interesting thing
that i learned
upon reading toby odds the precipice
which is going to contribute to
a big chunk of my understanding for what
we're talking about today
one of the things i thought was really
interesting was
technology is the cause and furthering
civilization
well-being further industrialization etc
is causing
many of the anthropic risks however
because the natural risk is non-zero
i.e if you run this world this planet
for long enough you would get hit by an
asteroid a super volcano would
come and [ __ ] the ass if that's the
case
you have to have sufficient technology
to be able to avoid that from occurring
so
if you were a militant luddite
and said well all that we need to do
just stop all technology stop all
industrialization we existed as
hunter-gatherers for ages let's just go
back to being farming people like 10 000
years ago will be fine
um that's not even an option because
from a
civilization standpoint eventually the
natural x-risk is going to catch up with
you
and you don't have any other technology
to save yourself it's true there
though there are schools of thought on
that as well um
there are many types of organisms that
have been around in an almost unchanged
state for millions and millions and
millions of years mostly marine animals
um but cockroaches and horseshoe crabs
are doing far far better than we are in
terms of longevity
and stability so um
on the one hand their rather simple
way of organizing and maintaining
themselves seems to be very successful
and you're getting into it like
basically eternity
at what at some point we will
be extincted on this planet um but at
the same time you know
580 million years as some animals have
are currently that's currently their
record like sponges
um that's a great run of it um and it's
clearly far more than we have yet pulled
off and it seems like we're likely to
so on the one hand um there is the
possibility
that regressing to
a more simple organizational structure
could create the longest term payoff um
and
but that's not really in our nature is
it i think even if we
wanted to go back to that sort of um you
know back to
back to nature type of organization
structure for that purpose i don't we
wouldn't be successful it's not it's not
what we do
and um i'm not convinced it would be
best anyway because
there is so much suffering in the
natural world and we have this constant
drive to eliminate
suffering and so this kind of
glorification
or romanticization of the animal world
um feels a bit misplaced to me i think
it's really unpleasant to be almost
every
other animal besides a human um
ultimately it's
you know very unpleasant to be a rabbit
being eaten by a fox
or um i mean throughout most of human
history the vast majority of human
history
and um in
the lives of most animals it's just
really really hard to be alive and
there's a lot of suffering
and so what you're pointing to with
these kind of parallel tracks or yes
our technological advancement is really
jeopardizing everything that we hold
dear
at the same time what it's making
possible is
something that you know a type of
reality a type of world without
suffering
that um has never we've never been able
to conceive of
um i mean just it's a funny thing to
talk about the massive amounts of
risk that we're facing right now given
the fact that our lives are so much more
comfortable and pleasant and the
possibility is so much greater
for nearly everyone in the world than it
has ever been by far
so it's um i think the way that i relate
to that
sort of dichotomy that dilemma is that
suffering is inherently like from an ab
psych perspective
more motivating than pleasure or
um or happiness and so it's it's more
you know we're more motivated to want to
avoid
a catastrophic outcome than we are
motivated by realizing this type of
utopic
future that we're hoping for do you
think that scales when we're thinking
about
civilization wide i think people are
quite capable of
being pain avoidant rather than pleasure
seeking um
when it's themselves but when you
abstract that to
even your town or at the very least a
civilization
like if if ever there was a year to show
us this as an example it was 20 20. like
the number of people that are saying you
know the the death rates
are so low it doesn't matter let's just
get the
economy started again that's very short
term is thinking i
appreciate that not everyone has the
utilitarian view
that our goal is to reach our full
potential as a spacefaring galaxy
colonizing civilization
which on the biggest biggest sort of
picture thinking that's what
we should be aiming for we should be
sacrificing everything that we can
in our lives right now in order to
ensure that the trillions that come
after us are still able to
to be alive um but people can't
think with that much abstraction not not
naturally not without
learning an awful lot yeah absolutely
gosh it's so interesting how my thinking
has evolved over the course of 2020
be due to watching um responses to the
pandemic
it's a really interesting example
because the coven 19 pandemic
um it it isn't quite
the level of uncertainty about it
shouldn't have been there that seemed to
have been there i mean we know that
pandemics happen
we know that pandemics at this scale
happen it's um
you know it's it's shocking to us
because we haven't experienced something
like this in our lifetimes but
we all knew like it was modeled like
that something like this was going to
happen
and we were completely unprepared
globally and not only were we unprepared
globally
but the fact that
so many people in the world are
i mean just caught up in these concerns
about whether it's a hoax or these
conspiracies i mean
it's really very simple measures that
need to be taken to control the spread
of this pandemic
that we all knew was coming and
i think prior to this year i had more
faith
in um the possibility of persuasion
mass persuasion and collaboration um i
like i would say that the number one
x-risk is really actually like
communication it kind of underlies our
responses to all of the others
collaboration as a global whole um
and i think watching the global
responses to covet it's very clear
that our communication and collaboration
systems are very broken
and things are heavily politicized and
the way to solve
i i believe climate issues and um
pandemic issues i mean you can only
imagine if this had been like an
engineered pandemic
with a high far higher mortality rate i
mean it would have been catastrophic
and that very well could happen in the
next hundred years it's like a one in
thirty i wanna say i think that was
ford's modeling the oxford guy um or the
chances of an engineer pandemic wiping
us
out within the century um
so i think ultimately it's going to come
down to technological development
it's not going to be something where
we're going to be able to sway the
masses and get everybody on board with
being very concerned about x-risk
because like you're like you're talking
about
the heuristics that we use to relate to
these massive problems just don't work
so our biology
and our psychology has really evolved in
keeping with the dunbar number which is
um it's like 150 it's the number of
people that we
are expecting to be able to form a
relationship with and
historically in a tribal setting would
have known
and so that translates to our sphere of
influence our sphere of influence is
effectively like 150 people except now
it's not
we had no we never had any concept of
force multipliers like we have now
and so our actions and our inactions not
only affect
can affect people all over the world
like i can donate five dollars to
um you know an organization providing
bed nets for malaria which i think has
been
um shown to be like the most single most
effective use of
monetary donation for alleviating
poverty and suffering
um and the impact that i can have is
huge
but i'm still operating in terms of like
expecting to see
people my community and build a
relationship with them and have a story
and influence them on this one-to-one
level so like you were talking about
offline we see a story about a little
girl
and we're so motivated and we might
waste massive amounts of resources
in a way that's you know ultimately not
very helpful
when we could have done much more with
that with those resources and so when
you
take it a step further and you talk
about like the infinite set of lives
that
don't even exist you know like i can
relate to my children it's a lot harder
for me to start abstracting out relating
to my grandchildren and my
great-grandchildren
much less like the trillions infinite
possible lives that don't exist and
valuing those lives
and giving them a spot in our policy
discussions and giving them
representation
and so really um it's a really hard
concept to get our heads around
and at this point i don't think it's
reasonable to expect that
of the general
discourse i think you're right and so of
course then
yeah um yeah i think the
the only other solution then is action
by really the technological elite
what's that look like um
i mean it would depend on on the x-risk
obviously like in terms of climate
change
um we talked about electric cars and the
way that those have become mainstream
and it hasn't been by
persuading a lot of people that this is
the best thing to do
in a moral sense it's had to just come
in through
um from a technological standpoint and
become a thing in the world that people
want to do for their own intrinsic
motivations
it's going to be the same for like um
animal cruelty or vegan foods and
you know things like that that are big
issues for people but you're never
you're never going to convince the
majority of people to be vegan even if
you know
whether they should or not is another
question from a health perspective
um but it's just not going to happen
until we get to a point
factory farming is not going to be
eliminated until we get to a point where
um we have we've
the technology is there and we've
provided a cheaper easier
better superior way of providing that
value for people um so i think with
virtually every
um every issue every especially every
existential risk issue
it's it's going to come down to the
actions of a few people in power
and the way that they're able to
reorganize and so
some of it feels a little gas lady with
the climate change debate this like huge
onus that's put on the individual
consumer
and the way it's you know the fault of
the average person that this is
happening if we drove less or we ate
less meat
we personally could alleviate um have
you had a look at this
have you ever look at like the stats on
how much
industrial units and large factories
versus
uh factory farming versus etc etc
contribute
as opposed to whether i need to buy
a light bulb which is three times the
cost but uses half of the energy
like have you had ever looked into the
differentials on that
i have um a bit and it's it's
it's really staggering um
it's it's like fundamentally it's not
going to happen we're not going to sway
the masses
and even if we did that's not really
where the power lies like the average
person
around the average person globally is
starving
they are not worried about their
contribution to climate change and then
even in
a wealthier western nation um the
average person
in america right now is struggling
through a pandemic and trying to feed
their family and so
we have this conflict of interest um
which is always there it's it's part of
it's part of nature even um you know
like
that most symbiotic relationship that we
know of like a pregnant mother
and a fetus it's really not that
harmonious that's the reason that
pregnancy
and birth are so fraught with danger
it's like the fetus has
an ultimate impetus of like completely
draining the mother of all
nutrients and resources so that it can
be very
healthy and robust and then the mother
organism
has an ultimate end goal of
you know giving the fetus enough to
successfully birth it
but to maintain as much as she can so
she can then go on and bear more
children
so there's at every single level there
is
always this conflict between being um
an individual actor in a system a cell
in an organism
and part of this macro organism and so
at every level we we see that what's
your
if you were to do a rundown mara's
top three most likely existential risks
to look out for
over the next hundred years what would
they be starting at number three and
then working to number one which would
be the the biggest risk
starting at number three well some of
this has been modeled
so of course there's so much uncertainty
that's the difficult thing with modeling
it is
it's always it's always kind of a guess
no one's going to hold you to it if
if it happens they're all going to be
dead so if you get it right it doesn't
matter right
if you get it wrong if you get it wrong
they might have a problem but if you get
it right it doesn't matter
well the one that um i might put at
number three would be
the unknown unknowns so 50 or 100 years
ago
the major risks that we see today we
hadn't even conceived of i mean there we
had no language to
discuss um some of the environmental
issues we're facing as well as
you know the idea of bio weapons at the
scale or you know
like mass deployed autonomous drone bot
that are you know nanotechnology i mean
that type of
risk was not um even in our parlance
so that risk of the unknown unknown i
think is quite real
within the next 50 to 100 years and
um and that's something that is
difficult to prepare for and the only
way i think to
take it on head-on is to
look at our mitigation methods and to
invest in much in r d as we can
but then beyond that it seems like
i i want to say i actually don't think
that i i don't know if i would put
climate change in the top three i would
say
bio weapons and
what's called like misaligned artificial
intelligence might be
the top three so i think the unknown
unknowns
is a really clever answer that i didn't
think of but
that would be mine as well i guess
i don't know i'm not i'm not
sufficiently familiar with
nanotechnology and whether
how that or a worry of that would be
distinct from
misaligned agi um like the grey goo
concern that we have like where does the
line get drawn between that and agi does
that make sense like does nano
technology fall underneath
could it even realistically be deployed
on mass
at that level of sort of capability
without some sort of artificial general
intelligence over the top
but yeah i think i think that's not a
bad that's not about top three
um should we talk about what you would
do
if you're in charge of the world to make
the public more aware
of the impending existential risk
yeah um it's interesting i do think
about this a lot i'm curious
when i talk to people it seems like
there's some amount of awareness but
it's something that
we don't want to think about and in my
generation i'm like
older gen z young millennial um there's
there seems to be quite a bit more like
as someone who was not old enough to
remember 9 11
like our whole um
our whole coming of age has been really
dominated by this talk of existential
threats so i i do see in like the
younger generations it seems like
there's more awareness
but at the same time it's almost like
i mean it's such an abstract problem
that's so hard to wrap our heads around
and it feels so
helpless i feel so fruitless we feel so
small
and so one of my main focus over the
last year
has shifted to how do we relate to these
risks on an individual level because
i could i have all sorts of
prescriptions about ways we can mitigate
um each of these individually and at a
collective level
but um there's some amount of hubris and
assuming that my policy recommendations
would
um ultimately be the right thing to do
and there's also the fact that i have
very limited
influence i couldn't i can't actually
enact any of these things
but as a member of the human species i'm
like deeply concerned for our future so
how do i relate to that
and how do i balance this need to live a
fulfilling
and fully developed actualized life
with the need to safeguard our future
so for some people that's not even a
given it's not even a given for many
many
people that i've come across that the
future of humanity is worth
safeguarding um i have an inherent value
on consciousness
i believe it is a gift back to the
universe in a sense knowing the universe
as it is is a really beautiful thing
um and as far as we know existence is
better than non-existence or at least
it's more interesting
so it's inherently it's like an a priori
good
um and at the same time there are many
people who do feel that that suffering
given that you know it's
it's more of an um it's more of an
impetus
it can out it outweighs that happiness
um or that pleasure that we
receive throughout the course of
existence and so is it even worth
um safeguarding and obviously these
people don't exist yet so it's kind of
like
in religious communities where they like
have to keep popping out more and more
babies because
inherently more life is better than less
life that's like the ultimate end of
that line of thinking
um so there's some balance where
is it true that inherently more life is
is better than less life
how do we put a value on the unknown
amounts of suffering that might be
persisting in the future so if we can
create this sort of society that
seems to be on the horizon in terms of
greatly diminished suffering
and greatly diminished poverty um the
world over
in technological advances i mean like so
the poorest people in the world today
are still considerably better off than
in many ways than um
well i don't know i don't want to say it
quite like that but they have
the poorest people in the world today
still usually have access to things that
the richest people in the world didn't
have a hundred years ago so there's this
there's still an asymmetry but the
quality of life overall is so
um it's so fantastic and
it's only going to keep increasing how
do we get people to think about this
like how can we drive this home um
i'll give you my prescription after
after yours
oh okay i'm so curious to hear yours um
i think it comes back to
examining heuristics and examining the
way that
we relate to all the information that's
coming in um
so i have i have all these motivations
for the things that i do
and some of them are conscious and some
of them are unconscious
some of them are conditioned most of
them are
most of them haven't actually been given
as much thought as i think that they
have
um even when i believe i'm acting
altruistically
i'm usually acting altruistically in a
way that creates a positive sense of
feedback
for me and that often is not the most
effective way to
to be so our idea of saintliness
or goodness or morality are still really
caught up in that dunbar number
um type of society where i see a person
i make them smile
i get a feedback loop my mirror neurons
respond
and i feel like a good person and now
i'm contributing to the world
and that's that's we need to like i
think my my prescription would be to
completely
re-examine our idea of morality so for
instance like
bill gates very well might be the most
might have done more good than anyone in
history up to this point
just by this year and that's not to say
that he's a particularly saintly person
like
but just that he has had more reach and
more influence
and he's relatively
strategic about the way that he
allocates funds
so actually looking at outputs and
efficacy and responding
and assigning moral value based on
real outputs and the way that they
affect problems in the world is
considerably more fruitful than um
responding from any other place
it's hard though we talk a lot on this
show about living a consciously designed
life
trying to get rid of the genetic
predispositions and the ways that you've
dealt with past trauma and the paths
passive least resistance
and everything like trying to deprogram
all of the programming and
be as conscious as possible with your
actions and your thoughts and your words
but the problem is i think we often do
the hubristic tendency of humans is to
believe just how [ __ ] smart we are
and we're not we're very very very
primitive and if ever there was a time
to see that
it's in the response to the pandemic
like
if you were if everyone had the capacity
to think on a civilization wide level
everyone who would have happily locked
themselves in the house
until every last drop of covid left
but we don't we've still got a lot of
personal motivations
that are these like archaic hangovers
from a time where we needed to be tribal
we needed
to fight over mates and
resources and whatever you know pick
whatever it might be um
i don't think that the vast majority of
people myself and you included are
anywhere near
actualized enough to properly properly
know exactly what it is that we're
supposed to be doing
in order to be able to do that my my
only
your idea was much more abstract and fun
than mine um
mine is just to continue this
conversation
with guys like toby ord with guys like
nick bostrom and sam harris
who are sufficiently
charismatic they're at the correct
corner section of charisma
and understanding and that they can like
give them a ted talk give them 10 ted
talks
give them like every ted talk from now
until people believe that existential
risk is a big deal
and that for me is in 2020 it's how an
idea pathogen
really transmits it's by finding someone
who has
some social equity with sufficient
visibility and or reach or clout
and then just distribute it but at the
same time
there was that clip from i'm sure that
you saw of bill gates
at the beginning of this year where in
like 2014 he was like yeah the next the
next big
sort of risk that everyone's going to
come up against is global pandemics and
this video had been on like a
documentary really big documentary with
a production budget
and people were sharing it around going
like why didn't anyone know and it's
like everyone knew
like the only reason that you don't see
that is because there wasn't sufficient
reach on it
so just getting more charismatic people
talking about it is like
my solution but i know that really
individual actors it's the same the same
as us talking about how to change
climate change
like you could have probably 90 percent
of the population
be concerned about existential risk but
the top 10 percent that the ones that
actually influence policy in the
direction of civilization
if they if they're not on board or can't
be bothered or it doesn't make sense
to them the entire population
below them trying to enact change is not
going to make any difference
right yeah i think what you're pointing
at there's like these two
separate things that need to be in place
for real social upheaval or cultural
upheaval
and one of them is the sort of the
public
substrate which can be influenced
by getting more visibility in the ways
that you're describing with these
prominent figureheads
but um a great example would be like
what we're seeing in the us
right now with the blm protesting and
that was precipitated by george floyd's
death
and that particular death was not the
most gruesome
or the most offensive or the most
anything so why did it spark off this
summer of protest which is still going
on like in denver right now i mean every
single night it's still happening months
later
and um there was like fire outside of
the
police station down here the other night
um but
there it there's this uh michael white
was
the occupy wall street i was talking
about this recently there's not um
no matter how carefully you plan like a
rebellion or a revolution or an
insurrection
or demonstration like it's not there has
to be some sort of natural cataclysmic
event that happens right around the same
time that precipitates it so
um it can kind of feel like talking
about these issues
um whatever your pet causes
like you're you know you're just
grinding the wheels and
you're not getting anywhere and there
there's some amount of chance there has
to be
something that really shakes everything
up and and that's just
luck is that going to happen in time so
we're in the middle of a pandemic why is
everyone not thinking about x-risk now
right well um to some degree they are
i've seen quite a bit more
quite a bit of a rise in um
concern the word apocalypse i've heard
like
3000 more times than i ever heard before
and my life up to this point
um i think people are getting more and
more interested and concerned of course
this is this is
one particular issue that i worry is
um not representative of how
some of the bigger risks that we're
facing might take hold um
but i it does seem like it's a good time
to be to be talking about this there's
more
receptivity for sure it feels it's
palpable in the air people feel like
the world is on the edge of collapse
there's major natural events and there's
you know um threats of war and major
political issues going on and
the pandemic it's kind of kind of a
confluence of a lot of risk factors
um so but i do want to circle back
around to the
that concept that there's existential
risk
and then there's global catastrophic
risk
which is much more likely which is not a
situation like with climate change
the likelihood of all the humans being
killed in the near term is not really
that high but the likelihood
that the majority of the world is going
to become uninhabitable
lots of people will die and the
remainders will have
a really low quality of life is is much
higher and that seems to be more
motivating for people it's like we can't
abstract out and conceive of the lives
of people that don't exist
and might never exist but if we can
think about our children
suffering in a really unpleasant world
and think about the likelihood of that
it's quite likely and it's it's quite
unpleasant and i think some people would
probably prefer
non-existence to some of the types of
dystopian futures that we're facing
anyway well if it's just
everyone mad maxing around wearing
leather with a lot of stuff with spikes
on
like riding around in an old ford ford
focus or something
driving across the desert yeah i am
i have an interesting so if you i sent
you a video earlier on
david attenborough um where he was
trending on twitter today
talking about how important climate
change is and how
don't waste anything don't throw away
food don't throw away packaging don't do
the the planet is on the edge of of
collapse how correct is david's science
there
i didn't watch the whole video i didn't
see his the science that he
cited i did watch um i did see him
talking about the urgency and his
the critical um
impetus to get this out to the masses
and
it was interesting how i related to it i
really appreciate
sir david attenborough and his approach
and um he is definitely trending with
that
and at the same time it again brought me
back to that
you know um that question of how much
impact is this really going to have and
in what way
and in a really direct straightforward
way i doubt it's going to have much
impact like
the majority of people who were already
aware of their environmental impact are
going to continue to be and the ones who
aren't whether because they
are unconcerned um and unfortunately a
lot of those people have a very big
impact
um or you know they're just in survival
mode and it's not a priority for them
it's probably not going to shift that
much it there's you know i so i
my question is about who he is who he's
influencing and what the intent is
there um because the people with the
real capacity to make a change
are are in tech how would they make a
change
um so on the well on the climate side
actually
i would say more research like there are
still so many unknowns about what the
biggest risks are
and then in terms of switching to clean
energy
that's really going to come from from
the from tech it's not going to come
from
the individual the average individual
consumer so
i have curiosity around what the best
way to
affect and influence that is um
it does seem it does seem at every level
though to start with the individual
which is which is interesting it's like
fundamentally and this is why so much my
focus is on
personal um kind of self-development i
mean it's really the only thing we
ultimately have that much control over
but there's this a way of relating
with self-development as like an
internal growth thing
and then there's a way of just
completely moving past that idea of self
and seeing ourselves as a part of a
giant macro
organism like ants in a colony we're
like one being
and the more we can relate to that
the more that we can align all the
choices in our lives around that so the
more i'm
i'm operating from like it's it's like a
marriage of two critical pieces that
this is what i try to convey um when i
talk about it mostly it's
um it's alignment with the macro
organism
and then it's also like a rigorous use
of reason which of course is not to get
into hubris and to assume that we can
predict all the outcomes of all of our
actions
but it's a commitment to really charting
what are my impacts in my career
and the way that i choose to live and
how do they relate to the biggest risks
that we're actually facing
so i think there are people who are in
much better positions to make
major change in the world than others
and
the more that those people can be
reached i think the better but i don't
know that that sort of messaging
now is the time to recycle more now's
the time to
consume less is really going to make the
biggest impact it seems like getting
that point of self-development and real
like alignment
and real rigorous examination of impact
to the people who actually have a big
impact in the world ceos and
tech leaders and researchers and people
working in policy
um those seem like they're really
critical actions to take
how does that how does that land i think
so i came up with a
an idea a few months ago called the
improvement imperative
which was that it is your duty to be
everything that you can the reason being
that you can
impact the lives of the people around
you and if you raise them up then they
raise the people that are around them up
kind of like a positive sum effect a
positive pathogen i suppose that spreads
and for every one person that's able to
do that
for instance you know joe rogan how many
people's lives
how many eyes has he opened say what you
want about some of the stuff that he
comes up with like i don't like what he
says about transgender athletes
like right okay mate he's done 4 000
hours of online programming which has
reached billions and billions of sets of
ears
like how many people's eyes have been
opened to a different way of viewing the
world to be more reasonable to be more
nuanced to be more
you know complex to have their
self-development improved like that
is him contributing at around about as
close to a highest cadence as i can
think he could
and the opportunity for everyone to do
that whether it be
a single mom who's raising
two children okay i'm going to raise
these children to be as actualized and
happy and independent and positive
you know all the things that we know
that produce a good human as possible
there you go like that's that is that is
contributing
um but there's just
so much inherent tribalism and laziness
and there's
all of this stuff that we've carried
over from a time where we really needed
it but
in it's not fitness it's no longer
fitness enhancing it's no longer
adaptive
um and as the environment that we're in
continues to change as quickly as it
does
any adaptation that evolution did manage
to look out
would be completely past itself by date
within
15 years in any case pointless adapting
yourself to the
to let's say that you adapted a way to
um not become
addicted to a device that was in your
hand and that you wouldn't be able to
have your dopaminergic system
um manipulated by that 20 years time
you're not going to have a device in
your hand it's going to be attached in
your brain
and then in you know 150 years time the
transhumanism movement will be with us
and you won't even be walking around in
any case and you'll just have electrodes
plugged in
and you'll just be sat like that bruce
willis movie where everyone was just
like a weird
at-home fat weak guy playing a computer
game with their
model version of themselves floating
around um
but one of the things that keeps on
coming up here is climate change
what what has made climate change
such a high priority
highly visible existential risk
category issue for people to be bothered
about
why is it not that everyone is thinking
about the concerns with biotechnology or
nanotechnology or
artificial general intelligence which by
pretty much everyone that i knows
standards agi is the
risk to be concerned about over the next
hundred years and
greta thunder isn't driving to go and
see the deep mind people and talk to
them about have you considered your
alignment and control problem
do we have machine extrapolated volition
here so that we can actually try and
wrangle this thing back
like greta thunder shouting at adults
about the fact that they're not that
they're
wasting money on bottled water
right yeah it is interesting i've been
so curious about that as well we have
this whole
specter of risk assessment and response
that has had
varying degrees of success so to put
those to put them on like on a spectrum
um with climate change towards the
center on one hand there's like the
response to
asteroids um
that has been a very successful response
existential risk
granted the risk of being wiped out by
an asteroid is fairly low
um but still we had a great response to
it we didn't know
until the last 30 40 years
um that the asteroids were likely to
have been what
wiped out the dinosaurs that was that's
like really new knowledge
and that quickly i mean i didn't realize
it was so new because my entire life
it's been
something that you know the government
has responded to and now it's like it's
pretty nega
it was already fairly negligible and now
it's like you know
a microscopic risk because we have
charted
everything around us and we have a
really good we have really great
situational awareness in that regard
um but that didn't become politicized it
was something that like
it hit at the right time um
there was there was a few things that
happened all the same time it was like
we gained more knowledge about the
impact of an asteroid hitting the earth
um there were a bunch of movies that
came out around that time because
it was um it was a hot topic and then
there was the shoemaker levy comet
hitting jupiter so um and that was like
created a really big impact for people
and so it wasn't politicized and
everybody was able to get behind it and
it was funded and you know this one
country basically took it on and
kind of solved that problem for the rest
of us and then on the other extreme
end of the spectrum there's um these
concerns around um exponentially
advancing tech
that are pretty fairly neglected
there's not very much work being done
and then in the middle there's
there's this i think this perfect storm
that's created
all the fervor over the climate change
debate which is that on on both ends of
the spectrum it hasn't been heavily
politicized
and so we're either able to like
effectively respond or it's kind of left
alone but then when something gets
politicized for whatever reason it
becomes just
um there's this there's this fervor over
it and it
um it becomes a tool and a weapon
for people with completely you know
unrelated aims and goals
and skill sets don't don't forget that
there's people talking
about climate change who don't have the
first idea about what the actual stats
are
behind it now there's not many people
who are discussing the control problem
for agi
that don't actually know what's going on
but sadly as you get a problem which has
more
social signaling behind being associated
to it
people jump on board without having done
their research
right right virtually everyone has
an opinion on climate change so it's
quite natural i think that it's
that it's exponentially compounded into
this massive
um debate but it does seem to be i'm
much more concerned about the next
pandemic personally than i am about
climate change
and seeing our response to cope at 19
i'm even more so
so i'm curious about and also you know
tensions escalating as we're we're
coming up
um against our our election in the us
i'm very curious what's going to happen
but there's there are a lot of things
that
are not really being addressed at a
global level and i think what would be
really useful would be um to have more
more of a more of a holistic
like global agency focused on
mitigating x-risk and observing it
and like an independent agency really
focused on that so i work
in space i work in a space sector in
astropolitics so
a lot of what i observe is the way that
different space agencies in the world
communicate around politics
astropolitics right um
which is what it sounds like the
politics of space which is a fairly
um it's kind of like the wild west
there's a really small
degree of um well thought out
collaboration and foresight actually
going on in space law
it's a commons it's like how do how do
we how do all these different players
um governments and um
organizations and private companies that
are trying to utilize this commons
do so in a way that protects both our
our shared and our disparate goals and
make sure that it's not weaponized and
it's we've really done it's kind of a
[ __ ] show right now
quite honestly and so that has i saw an
article
that was decolonize mars did you see
this
i didn't see it oh wow this is so
so up your street so um james lindsay
shared it
basically the concern was that
colonizing mars is an echo of the
colonization
of the west by europeans
and the subsequent destruction of the
native peoples that were therein
we need to have a discussion about who
is going to colonize mars
and james lindsey quote tweeted it
saying we're having a discussion about
decolonizing a planet that we haven't
even colonized yet
right right oh that's so funny i have
heard that um
that debate quite a bit it is
it's interesting i'd love for you to
send that to me so i can i can read it
yeah
um yeah
there's so there's so much concern
around our technological advancement as
well as like moving out into the
universe and colonizing other planets
because of these concerns that will take
human nature with us
and that will just reenact these
atrocities everywhere we go
um and i have i do actually have more
faith in human nature than that
it seems like the more that we um the
more that we
are able to collaborate towards a shared
goal i always say the ends
are the means it's like as we
collaborate towards these sort of
massive
goals that surpass that we can't really
achieve as these individual
boring factions the more that um
things tend to smooth out all the way
down so i agree i agree completely i
think as well
the people who are the people who are
being selected for that as well
are going to have had some pretty
rigorous psychometric evaluations you're
not just going to get someone
who happens to become a neo-nazi halfway
to mars
like you know they've been through it
and they've dedicated
decades of their life to to this one
purpose
and for all that hollywood might decide
to dramatize the
the guy who goes crazy in space we're
yet to see that
i don't think there's any examples of
that now yeah we haven't done you know a
trip to saturn's moons but we've been
spent a fair bit of time there's people
that have done like 100 plus long stints
up there and
held it together pretty well um the
signs are
encouraging but you the thing which
struck me the most
uh upon like hearing uh chatting to you
over the last few weeks in preparation
for this and then also reading toby's
book
is that we are at the perfect junction
between
having enough power to be able to do
something that could
severely neuter our ability in future
and having nowhere near enough wisdom
to corral that power it's uh eric
weinstein
uh we are gods but for the wisdom
um yes yeah it's so interesting it
brings me back to the prisoner's dilemma
really
um how do we we are these individual
actors
and um we'll be much more successful the
more we
were able to collaborate towards a whole
but we
we don't currently live in a world where
that's entirely possible i struggle a
lot to keep
you know like everything going in my
life and um and i have it significantly
better than the vast majority of the
world and so
being able to have it's a luxury to be
able to focus on
the overall well-being of the greater
organism
um but the the oh who what was the name
of the guy who came up with
tit for tat that um way of resolving the
prisoners dilemma
rapaport i know the guy that you mean
yeah
rappaport i can't remember his first
name but um
yeah it's essentially like start from a
the the one algorithm that's so simple
that
is the most successful at returning the
prisoner emma is to
start from a place of assuming the best
intentions
and then to mimic whatever you received
from your um from the person that you're
working with
whatever their last move was to mimic
that and that's
that's the best chance we have it being
successful obviously we're in a very
complex world so it's not quite so
simple but
we are all responding you know am i in a
world where i need to really fight to
get ahead
um then that's what i'm going to do and
that's what i feel like i need to do to
stay alive and so i can't consider the
long-term health of
the rest of the rest of society there's
some amount of
um anti-social behavior that can be
tolerated in a society before it starts
to collapse and once it gets over that
line
you know there's massive collapse and so
that's why i think i keep coming back to
um
yes massive personal responsibility in
terms of
aligning ourselves with our impact
exercising full agency over everywhere
in our lives that we have impact but
also really holding accountable the
people who have the power
because it's highly concentrated and
those are the people who set the tone
for everyone else
and can help create this world and i
think we are moving towards it we're
moving towards it swiftly
this moving towards this world where
people can relax
into greater possibility and
begin acting in more pro-social ways
[Applause]
it seems to be what works and so human
we
will tend to default to what works
toby odd's um numerical values that he
gives
for society's chances in the future
make for pretty stark reading so he says
that the chance
that we go extinct or that we
permanently mute our ability to reach
our full potential as a civilization
within the next century is one in three
and
within uh forever is one in two
so the vast majority of rx risk is front
loaded over the next century
one in three so only a two in three
chance
that we decide to that we
actually managed to make it and then a
one in two and even like a time cost
that we do
after that what's your opinion what
would you
why would you put your numbers if you
were doing the same
equation yeah i don't know that i would
differ significantly it does seem to be
heavily front loaded
um it does seem to be an absolutely
critical juncture
and and that's one of the questions that
becomes difficult when modeling x-risk
too
is it just as it's impossible to account
for the unknown unknowns
it's also impossible to account for the
ways that are
you know we are adapting so for instance
a lot of
um we're very vulnerable because of our
dependence on the sun
and um if we are able to devise
new ways of nourishing ourselves without
needing agriculture
you know a lot of our major concerns
will go down quite a bit
like the life still might be very
unpleasant in in case of
volcanic dust and ash filling the
atmosphere or
massive global warming but we could
survive it if we
if we're more able to develop these
different sorts of adaptations so
i that should be more of a focus i think
than it is but it also skews our ability
to model
a bit so it does seem like ord is really
on point as far as any
modeling that i've seen and there's
always some element of uncertainty which
is that element of uncertainty is is
more of um
a stressor for me than than it is
soothing
so yeah it's interesting i think that's
where
um i come back to also like
chop wood carry water ultimately we're
at a very critical juncture
and you know things are in play there i
think we can
keep having these types of conversations
publicly and get as much
focus on these issues as we can and hope
that the right people
end up receiving the right messages but
fundamentally we don't we don't
ultimately have that much control
as individuals and so there's some
amount of getting in right relation with
that
and accepting it that i think needs to
happen
in order to face these issues we have to
be able to like eyes wide open accept
what does it mean for the interior of
humanity the entity of consciousness as
we know it to not exist
it's huge um and that becomes really a
metaphysical kind of
almost spiritual practice um
and that's kind of a whole other
conversation coming back to like
accepting that i am no i am not really a
self and
so when there's no self left maybe it'll
be okay
because only when you only when you
really understand that can you start
making really conscious decisions about
how to relate to it
yeah it is a um it's a blessing and a
curse to be able to step into our own
programming
i've been thinking about this a lot
recently because i've been spending too
much time with dogs
which there is no such thing as spending
too much time with dogs too much time
with dogs
that's impossible um but everyone's
looked at the dog
and thought i would be so brilliant if i
was that dog you know i'd just lie on
the floor and he'd look so happy all the
time and life would be simple and this
and the other
but the fact that we're the only
animals that we know of in the entire
universe
that can step into our own morality puts
such a huge burden on us
like the fact that in the words of
mutual friend daniel schmacktenberger
that we're not just uh cargo
on spaceship earth but we're crew it is
our job
to try and move the direction
of the only conscious beings in the
entire universe that we know of that can
step into their
morality and decide to girdle their
future in a direction like the lions
aren't making it to space
and as much as i'm terrified of
cephalopods and as clever as they are
they're not building rocket ships either
like for all
right for all the adrian tchaikovsky and
children of
children of ruin might want that to be
the case he
genetically modified some octopuses
octopi
in that and then they're flying around
in big orbs of what a wonderful book if
anyone wants to read something that'll
make your brain explode
um but that's that's not a concern it's
us it's on us it's
just on us we have fermi paradox
got no answer to that yet don't really
know where they are
if it's on the heads of seven
previous apes recently found electricity
within the last couple of hundred years
i don't know like it feels a precipice
isn't enough of a uh violent term for
toby to use
it should be like plank length knife
edge
right right and it's so funny to relate
to it that way too when you look at the
way
that that we that we wield this
responsibility we think in terms of
quarterly profits
and election cycles and these like
utter blips in time and then we plot
you know our goals around you know the
next four years or the next
three months and maximizing returns in
those time periods
um it really reminds me most of a
toddler in the way that a toddler
relates to the world and this very
short-term thinking
unable to make decisions or a teenager
maybe
that's i think i think or it actually um
makes that analogy as well that we're
kind of like
in our adolescence and the way that we
are
the way that we're um the way that we're
wielding that power really shows that
you know we're like smoking a cigarette
and
we don't you know we have no concept of
what the long-term impact of that is
gonna be
because we're so we're so focused on the
here now and we suddenly we have all
this power
and we have these lofty ideals and we're
using it in these different ways but
we're just we're really
lacking this uh this wisdom
and this
this systems thinking ability
so the question is how to quickly grow
up how to quickly up level that as a
cell like
not as the organism itself because each
of us is only an individual cell
um and it's it's it's interesting and
it's
amusing and kind of sad it is melancholy
isn't it
like when i find myself i find myself
feeling sort of very melancholic after i
read
stuff like super intelligence by nick
bostrom or uh the precipice by toby ort
um i i i it's weird it makes me
feel very grounded and very down to
earth in the same way that looking at
the night sky does
like it's kind of reassuring to know how
lit how small you are
and how limited your impact can be but
then
also gets me very agitated at seeing
both my own
and everyone around me wasteful use of
their consciousness
like you have this second and this
second and this second and this second
and how are you spending it
you're spending it thinking about how
amazing it would be
if that hot girl in work would come and
ask you out or like
and you just think oh my is this really
the best that i've got
like you know it's it's it is it's it's
a
an interesting blend right if you were
to
and um go on was just gonna
i'm not sure if you're familiar with um
integral theory and ken wilber's
work much but the way that he relates to
that is um to transcend and include so
we're not
we're not attempting to move beyond our
base instincts we're attempting we
they're a part of us
and everything that's a part of us
serves a function
so we want to transcend it and include
it and bring it up to that next level
of consciousness but not like reject it
so yeah this
is really base sort of things that we
deal with like
like jealousy or um insecurity
uh hubris lust like they seem
so pointless um and yet they're a part
of what
they're a part of what drives us like a
lot of i would i would bet
that a lot of people working um at the
forefront
of some of these fields and having a
really big
impact um at some level you know one of
those motivations is they want to get
laid and that's a thing and that like
motivates a lot of people to achieve
really highly
um or they want you know they want money
and there's usually not just like one
driver for why we do what we do
it's it's kind of about transcending and
including and channeling
those drive toward um
something that's aligned on every level
so if we can just like bring it out of
the shadow
like why am i doing this why do i want
this
is it really aligned with what's
ultimately going to serve
um as long as we're yeah i think it's
better not to like repress it
and um just try and force our way into
being this like super enlightened being
who only cares about
the whole integrity of the human race
it's likely to be less successful have
you seen the future armor episode where
they
create perfectly realistic human sex
robots
and everyone everything on the planet
grinds to a halt
all the scientists stop working all the
bankers stop working all of the road
cleaners
because like the subtext is any
everyone is just doing everything in an
effort to get laid
it's like futurama decided like macaroni
had a had a crack at that it's like
right it's the same as every rick and
morty episode like the painful the funny
thing is the fact that it's true
right exactly oh that's hilarious yeah
yeah i definitely
i think if any of us are honest about
what's driving us we'll find there's a
lot of things we won't find because
they're
too they're too unconscious um and then
there's a lot that
that we'll find that maybe feels silly
or feels
not super not super aligned with um
our higher order selves but they can be
brought into alignment
well the genes our genes are bastards
like they're so
like if you were able to bottle whatever
a gene has and then turn it into a spy
you would it would just be the best in
information agent on the planet like
james bond wouldn't have [ __ ] on your
genes if you were able to
manifest it into a human because what
you think you're doing and why you think
you're doing it
you don't have the first idea the more
and more i read about self-deception the
more that i realize that that's true
um so i agree i think there's an upper
bound on the level of self-insight that
we can have
and being aware of the fact that there
is an upper bound on it as well and
not becoming hubristic about your
ability to
deal with complexity and
self-development is also important
but that's a further stage of
self-development i suppose the
ability to understand how little you can
develop
um right it's a challenge so
to let everyone go away with something
that they can
think of or continue to kind of rely on
is a maxim or just a concept
what are the things that you wish people
would be more aware of
or what is something useful that you
think people can take away from this
conversation
so that they are able to think with this
more systems-wide
mentality
i think um the most useful thing
that that i've done and it might seem a
bit counter-intuitive
to this conversation since we're kind of
focusing on these
you know these major systemic external
issues
um but the main the main way to really
understand them and have an influence
that's positive
is to be constantly um assessing
everything that goes through your head
every all the information that comes in
and though the responses that we have to
it and the way that we want to respond
in the world the way that we want to act
on it
and making sure that we're really
rigorously analyzing them
um i think we have a huge responsibility
to
the rest of humanity and all those lives
yet to come
to do to be doing so because our impacts
are so huge right now and the time is so
critical we don't have a choice if we we
had been born
in a different time period where our
impact was much more limited
we might have more of um
an excuse to kind of puts along
and um remain more in shadow and in some
amount of unconsciousness
but as as difficult as it is um
that work of rigorous assessment um
is is really critical right now
i hope that that's going to inspire many
people to go and do that consciously
designed life is
a term which continues to come up in
what i talk about with whether it's
james clear talking about habits or
james altucher talking about jumping the
queue or
daniel schmacktenberger talking about
sensemaking or yourself talking about
existential risk you know
the ability to step into our own
programming and consciously choose the
things that we do and understand our
motivations for doing them
it seems like there's very few downsides
to that
and the more that we can focus on doing
that on an individual level the more
that the
improvement imperative that i discussed
earlier should
expand out and influence more and more
people
um do you feel is the last question for
you actually do you feel
given your particular area of expertise
and skill set and the fact that you're
still young
and this time of our civilization
do you feel a particular level of
pressure or do you notice other people
within your industry feeling a
particular level of pressure to think
yeah [ __ ] like it is on me you know if
something bad's gonna happen within the
next century and you're gonna probably
be around for
another sort of 70 or 80 years of that
like do you feel
holy [ __ ] there's quite a bit of quite a
bit riding on my head
right well i heard two separate
questions which have two separate
answers one is do i feel that way and
one is do
some of the people that i work with feel
that way i work in aerospace and defense
and primarily i don't i don't see
too many of my colleagues feeling that
way both in academia
in the policy world and um
and then i work also in the startup in
vc worlds in aerospace and
i don't there's a lot less focus than
than i would like on what our ultimate
impacts are there's still this
this short term thinking there's
pressure but it's the pressure of
quarterly returns not
of um the ultimate end of humanity
so but then do i feel that pressure i do
i very much do and it does seem like uh
more of the younger people inhabiting
this space feel more of that
is what i'm observing anyway anecdotally
um
so i do feel that pressure and at the
same time as i learn how to relate to it
i
i become more and more at peace with it
it's the it's the chop would carry water
way of relating to x risk it's like
i have there's this pressure that's so
massive all i can do
is all i can do is really transcend
myself to be able to influence it and
then in doing that
in doing that i self-actualize it's so
interesting it's like the one thing that
is actually the best predictor of
physical health mental well-being
all around just thriving
as a person is your ability to live in
community with other people and be a
part of something bigger than yourself
so this
ends are the means it's like as i take
on this massive thing that i feel so
much pressure about the more
i become at peace with myself in my life
and um
i hear that experience from others as
well i think so jordan peterson isn't
that the purpose of life is to find the
biggest weight that you can bear and
bear it
um and we don't get our fulfillment from
rights we get them from responsibility
and you take on responsibilities you
pile on that weight and some people have
big shoulders
like you and some people might have
different shoulders
and yeah it's the duty of all of us to
try and find where that weight
lies well i hope that we haven't given
anyone an existential crisis talking
about existential risk for so long today
um but if there is anything where should
people go they want to check out some
more of your stuff or they want to read
a little bit more about this where
should they go
uh yeah no not.org
is um a think tank that i founded two
years ago
um and i do some amount of writing there
we also do some consulting
and then um at the astropolitics
institute i'm the executive director
there and we
published the scholarly journal of
astropolitics which focuses quite a bit
on a lot of these issues from a
space-based perspective
you know what you need to do you need to
speak to the people at apple
and get them to auto add astropolitics
to the
dictionary because it's not in the
dictionary just written it out on a note
there
and that's when you know you've made it
when your industry
has made it into the dictionary on
i know that's how you know it's done
look mara thank you
so much for coming on i really really
enjoyed this it's been a conversation
i've been looking forward to for a long
time
and um hopefully we'll have a reason to
loop back and say look at all of the
progress that we've made i hope so
yeah thank you so much
you